Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two David Pakman.
Here is a left wing gun owner and she calls
in and she says perfectly, Nobody's coming
for my guns.
Democrats aren't coming for my guns.
Why are people worried about this?
And she's completely right.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 7: Hi, this is Joe from Virginia.
Please, maybe you could explain to me why
the right thinks that the Democrats are coming
for their guns.
I mean, I'm a I'm a leftist.
I am actually an independent leaning left.
I but I have a gun, but I don't feel threatened
that the government is coming for my gun.
So maybe you could explain to some of us why
the right is so irrational about that.
They're coming for their guns.
I just don't understand what the problem is.
Speaker 1: It's two things.
Listen, you're absolutely right.
Democrats aren't coming for your guns legally.
We have a Second Amendment.
Legal gun owners are going to be able to continue
owning.
If anything even changes, legal gun owners
will be able to continue having their guns.
There might be some restrictions around the
edges on certain types of high powered firearms
or, you know, limited things.
There are two things that are going on.
One, this stuff plays really well in activating
right wing gun owners.
To say that Democrats are coming for your
guns gets people to go out and vote against
Democrats.
Number two, the gun lobby, including the NRA
and some other smaller groups like gun owners
of America, if it's still around, and others,
they sell lots of guns for their clients,
which are the gun companies, the manufacturers,
by saying either Democrats are about to come
and take your guns or look at all these shootings,
it's really unsafe.
You've got to go and get guns to protect yourself
no matter what's going on.
If shootings are down, they would say they're
down because people have guns.
Go get guns.
If shootings are up, they'd say it's dangerous
out there.
Go get guns to protect yourself.
If a Democrats in office, they say they're
coming for your guns, you've got to go out
and get more guns.
So all of that together leads to exactly what
Joe is describing.
Very well said.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
The Supreme Court is restricting police powers
to enter homes without a warrant when the
crime one is suspected of as a minor crime.
We'll talk more about that.
We will talk about the identification of twenty
nine planets from which intelligent life could
observe Earth.
And we will also talk about Canadian lawmakers
at the federal level passing a bill which
criminalizes LGBT conversion therapy, so-called
so-called.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom to get instant
access.